i love this man i've known him for a
long time uh he and my wife have known
each other for even longer
uh totally uh thrilled that he said yes
that he was available to call in on this
first day on peacock he is one of the
top
basketball players of all time top 50
hall of famer and
love seeing him and ernie and
the jet who's going to be joining us in
the middle of this week and of course
charles
do their thing on inside the nba it's
it's like watching family get back
together
and it's like good for the soul watching
these guys do their thing
uh on tv he's shaquille o'neal how are
you shaq
that was the best intro i've ever had in
my life and the check is in the mail
yeah i appreciate it i meant every word
i meant to work it's it's i mean over
here
[Music]
it's the truth and even you know that
set you know it looks like it's as wide
as airplane wings on an air
on an airplane but it's just great
seeing the four you guys together
it really is sure jack it's it's nice to
be back
uh you know this is a different type of
play of adventure that we're all
not used to seeing but so far it's been
it's just been living up to
it's it's building and uh you know i
wish everybody will
portland l.a has been a good series
clippers and dallas series just turned
around
last night doncic with the buzz uh with
the buzzer beater 40.
uh philly swept you know
indiana heat uh you know about to be a
sweet maybe so
it's been pretty good tohanosu it's
actually been
been very very exciting are you in those
hallways that are right outside your
uh you know all the uh the studio there
in atlanta is that where you are
no i'm not i'm i'm actually at chuck's
hotel is anybody looking for chuck he
lives at the four season hotel
on the resident side i'm here i'm here
uh i'm here having lunch and i guess
they're doing some uh
some construction construction work okay
well i'm glad i'm glad everything's all
right uh
so what what it where does doncha's
performance
leap out what what what does that leave
you with that was amazing that got me
off the couch that was amazing
what did you think no look he's he's
listening he's a great player
uh you know he's a
a lot of people don't understand like
you said european players
but if you really look into a dichotomy
of a european player you ever see those
stadiums they play
those are some rough stadiums so if this
kid was able to be a professional
15 16 years old i should tell you
something about his makeup
and she played something about his heart
so i'm not surprised to see him come
over here and do stuff like that
because the gap between european and
american basketball
isn't like it was in 1992 or 1996.
he played in the dream he's very very
close
is chuck looking for something to eat is
that what and what in the heck is going
on back there shaquille o
should you get a hard hat on and tell
these guys to stop waiting what is going
on
i'm actually on the first floor there in
the second floor aren't you letting me
go to the restaurant well i mean i know
you're tall so if your phone's to your
ear right now you're
pretty much damn near on the second
floor pretty much so i understand that
you know what let me
you want me to go outside yeah yeah
maybe so if you don't mind you kill
o'neill here i'll hear i'll tap dance
you know what ernie does so
here's walking hours
is it raining i don't want you to be
nope nope i'm going outside
okay that's it getting away from
whatever the hell
it's crazy what is happening right now
there we go
i think that's better right can you are
you are you nice and you're fine
wherever you are yeah i'm good okay
sounds much better oh my god
better my gosh i was that was giving me
a headache
so okay so uh ask the poll question of
shaquille o'neal i'm curious to know
what he has to say because this is also
factoring in what we saw from donovan
mitchell last night go for it chris
yeah shaq so you're in charge of a team
which player
25 and under do you start your team with
giannis luca donovan mitchell
jason tatum
we'll go with yannis first okay why is
that let me tell you why
yep he's big he's strong and the way he
plays attract
a lot of attention on defense and i'll
put i'll put
two pound fours with him and ten
shooters
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's it okay joe harris
guys like that guys could just uh just
sit out and just pick and pop
and who would be second on that list for
you would it be probably
yeah probably luca because one he's a
he's a fan favorite so on the business
side he's gonna fill the arena up
and he has a lot of swag and i could
tell that he's probably
mentally tougher than the other guys not
trying to be personal but
over there the european basketball those
people set fires and fights in the
stadium and do stuff like that
especially where he's from so you know
he's not from a country that that
you know producers saw people you know
we
you know we've had a lot of people with
this ics and the bics come to this
league
they all have been pretty good players
so i've always said anybody when i would
i see a [ __ ] in their last name watch
out so they can play
shaquille o'neal here on the rich eyes
and [ __ ] what advice would you give paul
george right now
uh pull your strings up and uh man up
like charles was telling me the other
day that he has the worst physical
percentage
in the history of somebody in the
playoffs so
you've got to look can't get no worse it
only get better and all you do is
one game to put one for the next round
now good thing about playing bad and
you're still in the series all you need
is one one you know
game that could you know just turn
around a lot of time i wouldn't shoot
another well it just seems to me the
clippers have a major problem with
doncic on their hands that they have
really no answer for him certainly with
patrick beverly hurt what do you think
about the rest of this series do you
think
the clippers can still pull it out would
you would you believe that they're going
to pull this out
i think that i think that can pull out
they need to pull up but we need a big
game from paul george
play rp where are you you call yourself
play op show me
show the fans why
i heard that from chuck the other day
nobody calls him championship chuck
that was fun that was laugh out loud
funny
man that was funny but he's right yeah
it's true
so um shaquille o'neal just a few
minutes left with you sir before i get
you ready for the rest of your day and i
appreciate you stepping outside
um so with with um
embiid and the sixers what's the fix
there what do you think is going to
happen what needs to happen in
philadelphia right there
i don't want to say i like brett brown
as a person but
i know from personal experience
sometimes you gotta look in the mirror
and say what magic
you want him to dominate his position he
played pretty good
30 but i remember one time i'm averaging
30
35 and he got swept and the great kareem
abdul-jabbar
said in a local paper probably said it
to your wife
that ain't good enough so mr indeed i
know you think you had a great season
but guess what it's not good enough
so you got to do more if you want to win
you definitely have to do more in this
league and it can be done and
uh you know if you want to be one of the
greats if you want to win a championship
you got to do it
so you know trump questioned this shape
i don't really question the shape but
you know sometimes you just have to like
i said look in the mirror and say okay
what can i do
because when you're a superstar when
you're the main focal point
all the praise come to you and all the
blame comes
that's just how the game is set up but
do you think that do you think
sorry no if you think the situation was
reversed though
shaq if if simmons was there and embiid
was out for all games do you think the
result would have been different
same thing when you're the star of the
starfield team all the
all the credit and blame goes to been
like that since the beginning of nba
time so
i know we're living in a new generation
but nobody's exempt
with michael jordan and colby and myself
and duncan all those guys wasn't exhibit
nobody's existed
well before i let you go uh when you
mentioned kobe's name and i'm sure
you'll be talking about him tonight
it is 8 24. it was his birthday
yesterday
tonight the lakers are going to be
wearing black mamba jerseys
uh with the number two and a heart uh on
the top right
of the jersey for kobe's daughter who we
all know
is no longer with us as well uh i'm
wondering what you're
you're thinking about today on the
subject of kobe
i talked about i talked about this last
night somebody on instagram and i hope
you can find the picture and show up
a couple of uh i made a photoshop
picture of kobe
in the 60s
and it's like when i saw that picture
like really broke everything down for me
because if i had one well i i got a lot
of wishes that i wish
i wish my father would do it my little
sister was here but
i wish that that photo could be true 20
years from now i wish
my old folks home or his old folks home
would visit each other
and hey man how you doing your
friendship oh man i got a grandson who's
having
fun like i wish that photo could be true
and unfortunately it can't be true and
it just makes you think about all the
other memories but if i had
anything that i would want for him
going forward it would be that picture
he's good he's bald he's great got a
great beard
i'm bald and gray was right there uh see
if you guys can find that and you know
put that picture up
and i want everybody to see what i'm
talking about we're on it we're on it
in preparation for this chat shack
before i let you go i mean that that
chat that you had with kobe sitting down
the two of you
for sort of a players only in february
of 2018
it was so moving to watch it now i
wonder what what what it what did it
take to get you guys sitting down
then what was that like it didn't take
anything
your wife can tell you i'm more i'll be
more of a media beast jim gray was his
guy
and jim hill was my guy listen you got
two
bullheaded guys jim gray writes
something like oh for real then i come
back and say something
but your wife will tell you in practice
she never saw us would have a problem
in games that you saw we were able to
win three and a half
listen you're going to have
disagreements you're going to have
disruption
as long as you've got respect nothing
you take that away
and you know for all the people that
really think we hated each other i
always tell them after my first
championship there was a hundred
thousand people in stable center
who's the first guy to run jumbo arms do
we have
arguments and disagreements what
brothers don't what business partners
don't
what producer and superstar doesn't have
disagreements but the respect was always
there and the respect is silver there
you don't have to be
go to dinner every night and people
think that's what it takes to win
championship there's nothing to do with
anything i know a lot of teams that
hang out and do stuff together but i
don't make you a championship team
love you shaq appreciate the call right
back at you
you take care of yourself get in there
and get your get get your uh get your
lunch on and have a good uh
broadcast tonight that's it you bet that
shaquille o'neal